I think Chucky did something we hope you
don't take it personally Chucky but you
didn't make it on our list of spooky
kids toys we mean you're terrifying and
all but you're a fictional character and
we're looking to cover kid toys that are
actually haunted in real life we've got
plenty of haunted toys that could give
you a run for your money but don't worry
Chucky you're still everyone's favorite
knife-wielding life-sized doll they may
look like everyday objects and toys but
the dolls on this list tend to spread
evil wherever they go you won't believe
how many haunted dolls have ruined their
owners lights for good keep watching to
find out which notorious doll inspired
the horror that is Annabelle letting me
out if you're ever in the mood to meet a
travelling haunted toy then you can make
your way to Australia where Walton and
his haunted doll letta traveled to meet
and take pictures with those brave
enough to cross their paths Walton
stumbled across Letta a 200 year old
Eastern European doll while exploring an
abandoned house Walton brought Letta
back home to his family and it didn't
take long for strange things to start
happening Waltons children reported
having nightmares of a walking talking
Letta
household item started turning up in the
strangest places and tiny little scuff
marks appeared on the floor overnight
some of Waltons visitors even swore that
they could see Letta moving after some
research Walton found out that Letta was
believed to be haunted by the spirit of
a young boy who had passed away
centuries ago but when Walton attempted
to sell Letta off he physically couldn't
get the doll out of his car now that is
just terrifying
Mandie the crying baby in the Crennel
Museum of Canada lives a doll named Andi
she was donated by a woman who
reportedly told the staff that she was
donating the doll because it wouldn't
stop crying at night the staff
graciously accepted to display the 20th
century European doll but it didn't take
long for them to find out that mandy
didn't play well with others
if mandy found herself in this same
display case as other dolls she would
knock them over until she was the last
one standing this resulted in mandy
getting her very own display case
Leigha not the museum's visitors often
report that their cameras are unable to
capture a picture of Mandy Ruby the
traveling Museum of the paranormal and
the occult isn't for everybody but if
you ever happen buy it make sure to stop
by and say hello to dear old Ruby before
being given away to the museum by an
unnamed owner ruby was passed down from
generation to generation but something
about the little doll just didn't sit
well with her family
for starters Ruby's first owner had been
a young child who had passed away while
holding Ruby in their arms and since
then whoever picked up Ruby would
immediately report feelings of sadness
and nausea to make matters worse Ruby
seemed to move on her own accord she
would continuously wind up in different
rooms despite never being moved by her
owners Elmo knows your name
Elmo might look like a cute harmless toy
on the surface but there's a terrifying
mechanical beast beneath that red fur
while most Elmo dolls are completely
harmless the Bowman family came across a
terrifying Elmo knows your name doll
back in 2008 after changing almost
batteries the Bowman's realized that
Elmo was threatening to kill their
two-year-old son James the Sesame Street
dog became fond of saying the phrase
kill James which ultimately landed him
in the trash bin dream with me Sofia the
Haunted doll is currently owned by the
htd paranormal dolls but before she
became a collectible Sofia was owned by
a little girl one day the owners
grandfather passed away and things began
to get a little paranormal the girl's
grandfather who is known for his
catchphrase come dream with me suddenly
started speaking through the doll itself
it's 2nd for the little girl to come
dream with it until her parents were so
spooked out they planned to get rid of
Sofia but before they could throw the
doll out both of them passed away in a
sudden car wreck Charlie Charlie has to
be one of the most terrifying dolls of
all time he was found in the Attic of an
old Victorian home back in 1968 the dog
was safely locked away in a trunk with
loose newspaper clippings that had
handwritten prayers on them the family
who stumbled across Charlie took him
down and displayed him with the rest of
their toys however the family soon gave
Charlie away to the local artisan
oddities shop outside of Salem as it
turns out the family's children were
terrified of the doll which seemed to
move around the house freely the
children swore that Charlie came to
speak with them at night and their
youngest daughter would wake up with
tiny scratch marks all over her arms so
long charlie you will not be missed
Annabel we all know the story of Annabel
the Haunted doll who went on to have her
very own movie and sequel but did you
know that Annabel was based on a
real-life Raggedy Ann doll before
finding her way into the Warren
collection this tall was gifted to a
nursing student by her mother in 1970
things got spooky when the doll began to
move on her own and leave little notes
around the house
a psychic later revealed that the doll
was possessed by the spirit of a girl
named Annabel do you have any scary doll
stories sound off in the comments thanks
for watching give this video a like and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more spooky Halloween videos we'll
see you next time
[Music]